all right this is uh standard in
kihon so kasushi
uh if you're rotating just around
your center that's not the aikido
position
so i'm not just tilting
his his center does tilt
but it traverses
across the sagittal plane
okay so here i am and
i'm gonna tilt it again do you see
it has to traverse again so
it's gonna move see
all right and the same thing when i do
so when you're giving me energy this way
when i do the reconciliation
it's going to move do you see and now
same thing here
don't tilt it it has to move
so as you're working your basics
pay attention warm
pull
and watch the okay that you're not
absorbing do you see because you don't
want to move because when we go quicker
you move deep see
so if we're going to slow it down stay
with the energy
you're good this reconciliation you'll
move
not just tilt you're going to move
you you absorb it in your arm again
right
[Music]
move the center oh move it again
it's going to absorb move
you're trying tilting it again whoa
do you see you can't take
okay so she's trying to get up
right oh when she tries to go ahead and
do
do it like a steady pressure so you can
feel it
so you absorb here you see and then i'm
coming
you can't not
your your role in suitcase
is not to make yourself more vulnerable
do you understand so over here
so what what hap why did you do it then
that's the question
you see why do it then let's look at
what's happening leave this arm long
okay and try to get up and do you feel
how
dependent you are yes
you see so you you feel your balance
losing
and you feel it losing here so you
trying to take that away but you create
the other opening
so you want to picture that you have to
defend yourself
you would not take that off
okay instead let yourself
fall there you go hi
which will happen when you actually
try not to let me in on you hi okay
so you start to lift up slowly without
taking it away
and this arm goes like that and you see
she moves
so here on on
her yawn move she will move forward
she will not stay still
she's there and i do all this and she's
there
okay she should be going in a kazushi
pattern
you did it again
you can't have your arm changes happen
people waiting so he's gonna
energy slow she goes don't give
up hi do you understand
try it again
oh there you go and then the technique
hi again
so first correction is obstruction and
understanding
this is dreamland she didn't move
second correction is the pressure okay
okay so here go slow so you can feel it
and watch your fear as you go
it's not there's no energy
just keep constant hi there again
see
you have to always be considering that
don't let that tie in
don't let the guy in there you go
up don't surrender
so when you lay down do i have to do the
technique
here okay